[Music]
they need these are Jordan Easter Peck
these were supposed to release last year
but they never ended up getting released
someone offered us like seven thousand
to take these but we're trying to get
around like 13 because this comes as a
set so you can't just draw both for 2004
12 no [ __ ] no yeah this right here is
the Freddy Krueger duck Duda like
copyright infringement it was actually
never able to get released so there's
only a few parents go out and heal did
you get though it was like jay-z Brody's
they got that little crease from
shooting dice on that this is how you
know today was in the trap do this
breach that's that I bet I hit C that
says about that
I got something for you guys to check
out say I'm talking about
so right here we got the Nike Air Mag
big hella light this is released only on
auction on eBay and originally there is
1500 pairs going right for those it's
right around nine donate my feet my feet
no oh I see the best of the best this is
gonna be our rarest most expensive
Jordan are just shoe in general this is
the best of the best right this shoe
right here is the best you you got in
here what are you looking for what is
really the green is my shoes oh it's
good well that is actually 172 parents
that were originally released at
undefeated LA and originally you had to
buy a shirt I came with a raffle ticket
but the chance to get a pair of those so
was an experience just give me my shirt
they get the ruffle ticket to put the
rubber tickets just to have a chance to
get one how much of these shoes was
Brooke the going rate when they first
dropped was around four thousand now
they sell anywhere between 20 it's like
twenty five dollars so 13 everything on
the street of the third right the only
way these could be worth 20 in my
personal opinion the right with me is if
Michael Jordan himself get the water or
he casts I'm gonna do with the finally
finishing touches on the truth what
makes these twenty thousand dollars just
the fact that there's only whole shoe is
this all gonna come up
here though that's all we've already had
out here for a month mm-hmm we got
offers but no serious offers yet really
we got hot first for 10,000 15,000 but
we turned them all down someone offer
you 15,000 you didn't say yeah you
turned it down so you have to get most
this this to come up definitely going
wrong I need to sell everything well my
my closet yeah that was my man Nick
Young swaggy P swaggy P junior alone
recall the real sneakerhead the man had
a crazy inventory I can't even a lot boy
has some shoes that cost $25,000 only
made 72 pair look like somebody cut the
grass actually black she might have warm
72 times for me when I paid $25,000 for
held on actually wish I had a whole
nother thumb so I give it three thumbs
down I would never ever [ __ ] my money up
like that
no that's just me but they did have a
crazy collection a real fan of the
sneaker the collection that they had and
I can't allow be going back not only
would I be buying stuff but I will be
selling them items as well so I juice a
little car keep doing what you're doing
Nick Young I'll see you on the court for
later doing all right for the first time
just cuz you 3 for 19
[Laughter]